our subject for today the cause of war
the cause
of war god spake all these words saying
i am the law of thy god would you
brought thee out of the land of egypt
out of the house of bondage
thou shalt have no other gods before me
thou shalt not make unto thee any grim
image
or any likeness of anything
that is in heaven above or that is in
the earth beneath
or that is in the water under the earth
thou shalt not bow down thyself to them
nor serve them
for i the lord thy god am a jealous god
visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children
unto the third and fourth generation of
them that hate me
ensuring mercy unto thousands of them
that love me
and keep my
commandments thou shalt not take the
name of the lord thy god in vain
for the lord will not hold him guiltless
that taketh his name in vain
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt thou labor and do all thy
work
but the seventh day is the sabbath of
the lord thy god in it
thou shalt not do
any work
thou
not thy son nor thy daughter
thy manservant nor thy maidservant nor
thy cattle
nor thy stranger that is within thy
gates
for in six days the lord made heaven and
earth the sea and all that in them is
and rested the seventh day
wherefore the lord blessed the sabbath
day
and hallowed it
honor thy father and thy mother
that thy days may be long upon the land
which the lord thy god giveth thee
thou shalt not kill
thou shalt not commit adultery
thou shalt not steal
thou shalt not bear false witness
against thy neighbor
thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's
house
thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's wife
nor his man's servant
nor his maidservant nor his ox nor his
ass nor
anything
that is thy neighbors
i'm grateful to god for this privilege
and it is a privilege to be with you
again this is the third day of the
five-day revival and i'm grateful to god
for the gift of life
the gift of the clear mind
the tremendous gift of knowing jesus
christ and as i said earlier the
privilege of speaking to you about
eternal things as they are recorded in
the holy word of god
thank you very much for taking the time
to be with us
i particularly welcome anyone who is not
a seventh-day adventist
thank you very much for taking the time
to be with us and i ask god very
directly to grant you a very very
special blessing and your children so
that you may be induced by the goodness
of god to come back and be with us
tomorrow and be with us on thursday i
welcome
little boys and little girls who are
listening
god bless you perhaps you're eight or
nine or ten or six or five
jesus was all those ages and he was a
very godly child and you can be a godly
child so thank you very much for
listening my little brother and my
little sister and as you listen and in
your mind you understand what i'm saying
i want you to say quietly lord help me
to obey you help me to be a little child
that makes you proud may the lord bless
the host church particularly bless the
host country of india and bless all
countries represented by those who are
listening our subject for today the
cause of war
the cause
of war
before i get into that message as always
i ask you as your brother in christ
preserve reverence where you
are be conscious of the fact that the
god of heaven and earth is present among
you in the person of his holy spirit and
he deserves our finest reverence so
please preserve reverence where you are
favor number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord put your words in
that man's mouth
jeremiah chapter one verse nine
then the lord put forth his hand and
touched my mouth
consider those words the lord that's the
almighty god the sinless god
put forth his hand
and touch my weak mouth and the lord
said unto me behold i that's god divine
hath but my words that's divine
in thy mouth that's earthly that's flesh
that's dirt that's the earth and i thank
god for that confidence and for that
assurance
ask god to do that as i speak favor
number three
think as you listen
use this that's why god gave it to you
think isaiah 1 18 come now let us reason
together set the lord the fact that you
serve god and god is all-powerful does
not relieve you and me of the
responsibility
of
thinking
if people would stop and really really
think they might not smoke they might
not drink alcohol they might not take
drugs if they were to stop and think
they might not be disrespectful to their
parents what am i doing stop and think
come now says god let us reason together
our subject the cause of war let's pray
father in heaven
i come to you as i came yesterday and
the day before
for this revival session
and i ask you to god first of all accept
my thanks for your goodness
thank you for your love
thank you for your protection
and thank you to god for extending to me
this great privilege of speaking for you
if i have offended you forgive me i pray
cleanse me by applying the blood of your
son which is the life of your son remove
every spot every stain
not from my sick dear god but that i
might be a clean vessel in your hand
that you may be properly glorified and
your people blessed
and as i mentioned your people bless
them right now as i speak their god
remember the guests those who were not
settled adventists who were listening
bless them in a very very special way
and their children
and father for those who have covered 19
i ask you now in the name of jesus
the name of the one who healed everyone
who came to him
touch them father and remove that
affliction i pray but not only covet my
key if anyone listening is sick their
god or if anyone listening has a sick
family member touch that person in mercy
their god because the bible says of you
you delight in mercy touch the person
and bring them healing and relief
now father
bless india that mighty democracy
bless the leaders of that country their
god remind them in your own way
that righteousness or right doing
exalteth a nation but remind those of us
listening that righteousness also exalts
the individual
bless every country represented by the
audience i pray please
and help me father to make this message
so simple that a child will understand i
pray from my heart in jesus name
amen
let us learn something about god
god
cannot die
death
is foreign to god in the sense
that god cannot die we learn from first
timothy chapter 6 verse 16
who only has immortality
god is immortal god cannot die
whether is god the father or jesus
christ before he became human let me say
that again before he became human
because christ was both human and divine
divinity that's perhaps a better word to
use
cannot
die
i say it one more time
divinity that will include father son
and holy ghost cannot die
let us learn something else about
divinity or about god
james chapter 1 from verse 13
let no man say when he's tempted
i am tempted of god
for god cannot be tempted with evil
god
cannot be tempted
two things
god
cannot die or let me say divinity cannot
die
point number two
divinity or god cannot be tempted
by the way nor does he tempt anyone
god never tempts anyone to sin so we
have a god god of heaven and earth
who cannot die
and who cannot be tempted but in
devising the plan of salvation
god had to find a way
to experience death
and
temptation
let me say that again in devising the
plan of salvation
god
the father god the son as they worked on
this plan the holy spirit as well
because the godhead functions as one
they had to find a way
for christ who was god
to experience death
and to experience temptation in other
words god had to develop a situation in
which he would experience something that
was absolutely foreign to him and those
things were death and temptation or in
the other order temptation and death
the answer to that was
to come as a human being
not a human being
in the condition of adam before he
sinned
but to come as a human being in the
condition of adam after he sinned god
developed a way to take upon him
fallen
weak frail human nature with all its
weaknesses when by weaknesses i mean its
capacity to sin
and so christ
god the son
became human
tremendous humiliation that you nor i
will ever fully understand the mighty
god who is so big we discovered that the
universe cannot contain him he found a
way to become one of us why that he
might experience temptation why that he
might experience death why that he might
pay the price for sin
the bible calls god the living god
john 8 57 as the living father have sent
me that's how jesus calls him paul
refers to him in second uh corinthians
chapter 6 verse 16 we are the temple of
the living that he is the living god god
himself is life
otherwise says god has given his life to
the trees and vines of his creation
every animal lives because god gives
that animal life every tree lives
because god gives life to that trait god
does not give death god gives life now
why would god
agree to make him put himself in a
position where he could experience death
the reason for that is
sin
not sin that christ committed but sin
that was committed
the bible says wherefore as by one man
sin entered into the world we know from
romans 6 26 the wages of sin
is
death
we know from ezekiel 18 verse 4 and
verse 28 the soul that sinneth it shall
die
we know from romans 5 12 wherefores by
one man's sin entered into the world and
death by sin and so death passes on all
men for being in because that all men
have sinned
wherever there's death there is sin
without sin they cannot be death
jesus christ who was god still is by the
way but who agreed to take our condition
he subjected himself to that humiliation
because of
sin
in order to pay the price
that fallen mankind may have a way to be
redeemed let me pray again before i
continue
father in heaven continue to instruct me
as i speak to your beloved people in
jesus name i pray amen
what is sin
first john chapter 3 verse 4 whosoever
transgresseth the lord's sinneth
transgressive also the law for sin
is the transgression of the law
our subject is the cause of war
the bible says sin
is the transgression of the law
now let me tell you very clearly
everything that exists
exists because of law
whether it's a living human being
intelligent like mankind
a living human being that is not
intelligent as we are
animals
planned lives
even inanimate things whether it's a
rock or
everything that exists
is governed
by law
and if you are
a
scientist you understand that
you understand that matter is governed
by law whether it's liquid solid or gas
all matter is governed by law
and that law proceeds from god himself
sin
is a violation of the law of god and
that violation extends from the moral
law the ten commandments but it has
repercussions at every level of
existence let me say that again when we
sin we not only violate the ten
commandments but the ten commandments
are the source of which all of the laws
flow why because the ten commandments
are the expression of the very nature
and righteousness of god
and so eloise tells us in patriots and
prophets page 52 paragraph three the law
of god is as sacred as god himself
i repeat
the law of god
is as sacred as god himself so when we
sin
excuse me we actually offend directly
and personally against god and so when
potiphar's wife tried to seduce joseph
to commit adultery joseph said how can i
do this great wickedness and sin against
god genesis 39 7-9 sin is an offense
directly against god when david prayed
in psalm 51 confessing his sin of
adultery and murder with uriah's wife
the lady called bathsheba he said
against thee the only have i sinned and
done this evil in thy sight
sin is a personal offense against a
personal god
there's no impersonal sin all sin
is an attack against god
because the law of god is as sacred as
god himself why the law is holy the law
is just the law is good the law as
romans 7 verse 12 the law is perfect
psalm 19 verse 7 and god is all those
saints
the sin
which is a violation of god's law is an
attack against god himself now speaking
about attack against god himself and our
subject is the cause of war let us go to
revelation chapter 12 we'll read from
verse 7
you know this passage very well
revelation 12 reading from verse 7 our
subject the cause of war
the bible says
and there was war in heaven
michael and his angels as christ
fought against the dragon and the dragon
fought and his angels and prevailed not
neither was their place found anymore in
heaven those who oppose god have no
right to reside in heaven
those of us who persist in living in sin
we shall never be taken to heaven the
same way living beings who oppose god in
heaven were cast out living beings who
oppose god on earth will never enter
heaven i hope i said that clearly let me
say it again by reading the bible again
revelation 12 reading from verse 7 and
there was war in heaven
michael and his angels michael christ
fought against the dragon and the dragon
fought and his angel the dragon is satan
made very clear in verse 9 of that same
chapter revelation 12.
nigh and they prevailed not neither was
their place found anymore in heaven
because they attacked god because they
sinned against god they were thrown out
of heaven those of us on earth who
persistently sin against god we will
never enter heaven the same way those in
heaven who attacked god were thrown out
heaven is not a place for law breakers
there was war in heaven
michael and his angels fought against
the dragon the dragon fought and his
angels and prevailed not neither was the
place found anymore in heaven verse 9
revelation 12 and the great dragon was
cast out daryl's serpent called the
devil and satan which deceiveth the
whole world he was cast out into the
earth and his angels were cast out with
him there was a war now what was the
basis the foundation of that war to
understand the cause of the war we need
to understand what mysteriously
developed in the mind of lucifer before
he became satan let's go to isaiah
chapter 14 we shall read from verse 13.
isaiah 14 reading from verse 13.
all let's read from 12 how thou fallen
from heaven o lucifer son of the morning
however thou cut down to the ground
which this weakened the nations for thou
has said in thine heart
i will ascend into heaven
i will exalt my throne above the stars
of god i will sit also upon the mount of
the congregation in the sides of the
north
i will ascend above the heights of the
clouds
i will be like the most high
somehow mysteriously in a way the bible
does not explain
a desire developed in lucifer to take
god's place keep in mind lucifer was a
created being
no created being can be god because god
is not created god creates
god is not created god the father is not
created god the son is not created god
the holy spirit is not created they are
not created they are all involved in
creation but they themselves are not
created a created being cannot qualify
as god as a matter of fact you don't
qualify as god you're either just god or
you're not god has always been god he's
always been there lucifer as i said in
some mysterious way
not explained in the bible he tried to
take god's place and to take god's place
you would have to remove god but in his
own mind he thought he would take god's
place
that's why the war broke up verse 15
says yet thou shalt be cast down to hell
to the size of the pit
that's what is done to sinners
lucifer therefore sinned against god by
desiring god's position let me say very
quickly you and i must desire god's
character
not god's position
that's lucifer's mistake lucifer wanted
god's position not god's character you
and i must desire the character of god
and that character is in the person of
jesus christ we're not to desire the
place of god we are to desire the carrot
of god we are to desire the
righteousness of god the holiness of god
the forgiving nature of god the
long-suffering nature of god the
patience of god the goodness of god we
must desire that we must never desire to
take god's place
the cause of war
is our subject listen to what jesus
christ had to say about lucifer or satan
let's go to john chapter 8 we'll read
verse 44. now jesus who walked on the
earth was the jesus who fought satan
long time ago and so they knew each
other because as a matter of fact
lucifer was created by christ i never
said satan i said lucifer the lucifer
the perfect being was made by christ
the bible tells us ezekiel 28 verse 13
verse 15 that lucifer was created and
the active creator is jesus christ
john 8 reading verse 44 i will subject
the cause of war let me pray again
father continue to tell me what to tell
your people
and help me to say it as simply as i can
in jesus name i pray amen
listen to what christ
told the scribes and pharisees
ye are of your father the devil
and the lusts of your father you will do
he was a murderer from the beginning and
abort not in the truth because there is
no truth in him
when he speaketh a lie he speaketh of
his own so he is a liar and the father
of it now christ accused the devil of
two things in that verse
let's read the verse again let's read it
microscopically our subject the cause of
war
ye are of your father that by the way
god is not the father of everyone
jesus is very clear you are of your
father the devil those who knowingly and
i use the word carefully consciously
deliberately intentionally and
flagrantly violate god's law make
themselves children of satan not
children of god
year of your father the devil
and the lusts of your father he will do
now listen carefully he was a murderer
from the beginning that's violation of
commandment six thou shalt not kill
he was a murderer from the beginning and
abort not in the truth because there is
no truth in him when he speaketh a lie
he speaketh of his own for he's a liar
that's violation of commandment 9 thou
shalt not bear false witness it is also
violation commandment 3 thou shalt not
take the name of the lord thy god in
vain
you claim to be a christian you live
differently that's a lie
lucifer
broke the law of god
he was a murderer
he was a liar and based on james chapter
2 verse 10 whosoever shall keep the
whole law and yet offended one point
he's guilty of all this created being
called lucifer broke the law of god and
he had to be thrown out and the wages of
sin is death and we know from first john
chapter 3 verse 8 he that committed sin
is of the devil for the devil sinneth
from the beginning and the wages of sin
is death lucifer who became satan he
sinned by violating the law of god
the angels who followed him they
violated the law of god
when adam sinned he violated the law of
god
why are there still some angels in
heaven that were not thrown out because
they obeyed and obey the law of god go
with me to psalm 103 we shall read verse
20. psalm 103 verse 20 our subject the
cause of war and the cause of war was
sin and we have discovered that sin is
the violation of the law of god and so
the cause of war was the law of god
psalm 103 verse 20
bless the lord ye his angels
that is selling strength that do his
commandments heartening unto the voice
of his word do his commandments that
statement and hearkening unto the voice
of his word are the same thing
to give you a fancy expression that may
be called hebrew parallelism parallel
lines run together
heart who do his commandments that's one
line hearkening unto his word another
lie they're saying the same thing
another example by the word of the lord
with the heavens made on all the hosts
of them by the breath of his mouth same
thing for he spake and it was done he
commanded it stood fast same thing
bless the lord ye his angels that excel
in strength that do his commandments
there obey god
heartening unto the voice of his words
same thing the word of god is the
commandment of god the angels that
remain in heaven they remain because
they obey god those who were thrown out
were thrown out because they disobeyed
god
let me tell you something now about the
law of god
in
of prophets page 49 paragraph 1
pages and prophets page 49 paragraph 1
god placed man under law
by the way based on psalm 103 verse 28
he had previously placed the angels on
the law god placed man under law it
wasn't adam's choice adam was made under
law
god placed man on the law
so we were made to obey law and the only
way to please god is to live an obedient
life god placed man on the law as a as
an indispensable condition of his very
existence
nothing can exist without law
listen again god plays man under law as
an
indispensable condition of his very
existence
let me give you a personal example of
law
right now
you are breathing
you're breathing in oxygen so am i
you're expelling
carbon dioxide
it's poisonous we don't want it staying
in the body
how does that happen
there are laws
that allow the oxygen in the lungs to
diffuse into the bloodstream there's a
law that allows the carbon monoxide in
the blood to diffuse into the lungs to
be expelled there are laws and those
laws are sophisticated they're somehow
connected with atmospheric pressure it
is very complex it's all functions by
law violation of law is an attack upon
the universal system
yes let me say it again
one little human being
by sinning in that sin has launched an
attack against the universal system of
god because god's arrangement was
everything would function by law every
violation of god's law is an attack
against the system that god set up and
so satan when he attacked god his object
was to overthrow the law of god
but to show you how suicidal sin is by
overthrowing god's law by attacking
god's law satan put his life in danger
because one day he will surely die he'll
perish sin is so suicidal sin does not
allow the sinner to realize that sin
disobedience to god's law is suicide
because there is no life
without law
romans 7 verse 10 the law which was
ordained to life i found to be unto
death why when we disobey the law of
life
the punishment is there satan attacked
the law of god
he has thrown up because god's law is a
secret of god himself and to attack the
law is to attack god i'll tell you
something else about the law of god we
live in a world of biblical error
i don't say we live in a world where the
bible has errors we live in a world of
biblical error in the sense people
misunderstand the bible and they preach
error and two of the biggest errors are
that when you die you're going to have
no hell immediately your soul remains
alive the second big error is that the
sabbath is sunday those are two massive
errors errors which most of the world
follows but they are not biblical at all
now i told you let's learn something
else about the law
signs of the times april 30 1896
paragraph one
signs of the times
april 30 1896 paragraph one the doctrine
which is the test at the standard which
is to test every doctrine every theory
every profession is the law of god
the standard
which is the test
every doctrine
every theory
every profession
is the law of in other words anyone who
preaches and that sermon minimizes god's
law that sermon needs to be avoided
i am not proclaiming legalism because
the law does not preach legalism the law
expresses righteousness and righteous
not is not legalism the law expresses
righteousness which is a very character
of god that's why the law is as sacred
as god himself and i say again any
sermon any presentation that minimizes
the law of god ought to be avoided
because christ who was god and still is
christ who was divine and still is while
he's also human he subjected himself to
be human in his fallen condition he
subjected himself to hunger to thirst to
pain to abuse he subjected himself to
suffer temptation he voluntarily
subjected himself to death why because
the law was broken
and so to minimize the law of god is to
minimize the sacrifice of jesus christ
another white tells us in last events
page 43 paragraph three
god has a people
a distinct people a church on earth
second to none
superior to all
if the facilities to teach to teach the
truth and to vindicate the law of god
god she's telling us god as the people
on this earth and i believe you were
part of that people to teach truth
and truth is only truth if it is
consistent with the law of god let me
say that again truth is only truth if it
is consistent with the law of god you
may say no truth is truth if it is
consistent with the lives of christ but
the life of christ was consistent with
the law of god that's why but now the
righteousness of christ apart from the
law is
is manifested being witnessed by the law
the righteousness of christ's life is
supported by the law of god because the
law of god is the standard by which he
measures righteousness by which he
measures truth and error the law of god
any attack against god's law is an
attack against god and god has a people
on this earth to vindicate his law
because law
is life
let me say it again law
the law points out to the sinner his
transgression
but it does not make a way out
while it promises life to the obedient
it declares that death is the portion of
the transgressor great controversy page
476 467 paragraph three the law reveals
to man his transgression but provides no
remedy
while it promises life to the obedient
it declares that death is the portion of
the transgressor of the disobedient the
law of god its original purpose is life
it still is
that's why paul says
no ye not that to whom you yield
yourself servants to obey his servants
you are to whom you're there whether of
sin unto death of obedience unto
righteousness the law of god is a law of
life
sin entered
and the law had to condemn sin and the
punishment for sin is death now let's
take that look at that but let me pray
again father as i continue and i'm not
far from finishing god but you continue
to speak through me in jesus name amen
the law declares that the punishment for
violating it is death
that tells you how serious god is
against his law that god's response to
any attack on his law is death and by
death i mean a death from which there is
no return
that's how serious god is about his law
violation of god's law is not punished
by two weeks in prison
or by signing you thirty thousand
dollars god's punishment for violating
the law is death when i say death i need
the second death from which there's no
return
how christ came back from it is a
mystery we'll study forever because he
paid the price
the cause of war
the law of god
great controversy
excuse me page 582
paragraph one
great controversy page 582 paragraph one
i just checked the time i have a few
minutes left
listen very carefully from the very
beginning of the great controversy in
heaven
the strife between satan and lucifer and
christ
it has been satan's purpose to overthrow
the law of god
it was to accomplish this
that he entered upon his rebellion
against the creator
and though he was cast out of heaven he
has continued the same warfare upon the
earth
my little brother my little sister let
me talk to you
while the adults eavesdrop
when you disobey your parents
you are doing what the devil wants you
to do
it is the devil who gets you to disobey
your parents because the devil wants to
destroy you the devil knows that the law
says honor thy father and thy mother
when you disobey the lawful words of
your parents and i say love
because i've met some children who told
me their parents wanted them to study on
sabbath and their parents wanted them to
work on the sabbath you cannot do that
and so when you disobey the lawful words
of your parents you are cooperating with
the devil my little brother you are
cooperating with the devil my little
sister obey your parents why because
you're living in harmony with god's law
the punishment for law breaking is
death
that person must cease to exist forever
that's how serious god is about his law
the bible calls it the punishment the
second death
that's the death that all stubborn
sinners who refuse to submit to god
will finally suffer
and from that death
there is no return the cause of war
the law of god let me give you that
quotation again
great controversy page 582 paragraph one
from the very beginning of the great
controversy in heaven it has been
certain purpose to overthrow the law of
god
it was to accomplish this
that he entered upon his rebellion
against the creator and though he was
cast out of heaven he has continued the
same warfare upon the earth violation of
god's law that's why we live in a world
of murder and all kinds of crime and
disease and disaster and war and
because the law of god is persistently
violating
persistently violating because satan
knows
violation leads to death and he wants to
kill you
and so jesus warns us in john 7 in john
10 verse 10 john chapter 10 verse 10 the
thief cometh not but for the steal to
kill and to destroy
that's it
i am come says christ
that they might have life
satan brings death
christ brings life i am come
that they might have life
and they that might have it more
abundantly in proverbs 8 verse 36 wisdom
is used as a symbolic expression of
christ and in that verse we read all
thieves that hate me
love death
all they that hate me love death and how
do we show hatred for christ listen to
the second commandment thou shalt not
make unto thee any grievan image or any
likeness of anything that is in heaven
above or that is in the earth beneath or
that is in the water under the earth
thou shalt not bow down thyself to them
nor serve them for i the law of thy god
am a jealous god visiting the iniquity
of the fathers upon the children excuse
me unto the third and fourth generation
of them that hate me and how do you hate
god listen to the second part of that
expression and showing mercy unto
thousands of them that love me and keep
my commandments notice that those who
love god keep his commandments well then
how do we hate god we disobey his
commandments and so the bible says all
they that hate me
love death proverbs 8 36 how do we hate
god we violate his commandments how the
satan expresses hatred for god he
violated he attacked the commandments of
god when you and i disobey god that act
of disobedience is an act of hatred
towards god
even a child of god in an individual act
of rebellion against god's law is
expressing hatred for god in that moment
of rebellion
the only way to love god and you know
the verse john 14 15 if you love me
keep my commandments
there is no other way to love god and so
in order to move or remove the angel's
love for god satan had to attack the
very means by which they demonstrated
that love and that means was the law of
god my listening friend
we are saved by the sacrifice of christ
but keep this in mind the only reason
why christ died is because the law of
god was violated it was broken
and the law of god is so sacred that
someone equal with god himself jesus
christ had to come and die many people
use christ's sacrifice to say he did
away with the law they do not understand
it is the very opposite the death of
christ demonstrates how much god's law
means to him let me check the time i
don't want to hold you very long give me
five or ten more minutes in the
construction let me pray again fathers i
come to the conclusion give me the right
words god please in jesus name i pray
amen several the adventists
we have an advantage not a church has
not that the advantage is not available
to other churches they simply do not use
it the advantage is the sanctuary
service
by studying the sanctuary service we
learn about the dealings of god with sin
and with sinners and how god makes
salvation available and how he
sanctifies justifies perfects and
ultimately saves and what he does with
sin
now in the construction of the sanctuary
god told moses the very first thing to
make was the ark exodus 25 reading from
verse 10 the very first thing to be made
was the ark and we know there was
several articles of furniture and
instruments associated with the services
of the sanctuary the number one the one
made first was the ark
the ark was a sacred container it
contained the law of god
loy tells us in the great controversy
page 433 paragraph two the ark was
merely a receptacle for the
precepts of god's law or for the tables
of this the law
and the presence of these divine
precepts give to it its sacredness and
value
it is only because the law was in that
box that that box became untouchable
the box itself had no value outside of
the law so the ark was untouchable
anyone who touched it died because it
simply meant by touching the arch you
touching god's law take your hands off
god's law the punishment was death so
the israelites were taught do not touch
god's law in a sense don't violate god's
law
where was that our place in the
sanctuary we have the outer court where
the animals were killed we are the holy
place we have the most holy god placed
his law
in the most holy place and the ark was
the only article of furniture in the
most holy place it contained the ark
what does that tell you god could have
placed his law in the outer court he
could replace his law in the holy place
he placed it in the most holy because
the law of god needs everything to god
and the israelites had to understand
the sacredness of god's law the high
priest could not enter the most holy
place with one sin on his life if he did
he dropped dead
he came into the holy place many times a
day he could only enter the most holy
once a year and he had to be sinless
why he came to the presence of god's law
which in a very real sense is the very
presence of god and that ark represented
the throne of god which means the throne
of god
is propped up by the law of god let me
say it differently the foundation of
god's throne is the law of god
let's go back to page have some prophets
page 49 paragraphs too god placed man
under law as an
indispensable condition of his very
existence he was made a subject of the
divine government
and there can be no government without
law
the universal government of god is based
on
the law of god as expressed in the ten
commandments let me say it again the
universal government of god
is based
on the law of god
satan wanted to overthrow god's
government the only way he could do that
would be to overthrow the law of god the
cause of war the law of god you and i
are coming close and quickly to the end
times
what will be the issue of contention
the law of god
it will be
concentrated in the fact that we will
have a choice
we accept sunday as the sabbath which
will be a common law we know that the
sunday law or we continue to obey god
the seventh day the sabbath the final
conflict will come down on this one
point will i obey the laws of man or the
law of god
i pray and hope that you will always
keep in mind that the law of god is the
standard for the universe on any request
any demand any command from a non-divine
source that requires us to obey to
disobey god's law must be avoided
and so you and i don't take exams on
sabbath because god tells us it's a holy
day
you and i don't go to the hyderabad
cricket ground to watch uh
uh sachin tendulkar back because that is
a holy day
we do it we obey because god's law is
holy and it expresses the will of god
the will of god for the universe the
will of god for this earth the will of
god for your personal little world is a
life of compliance with the law of god i
give you one more quotation then i pray
signs of the times september 24 1894
paragraph four signed the times
september 24 1894 paragraph four let me
pray father i'm about to end continue to
bless me with clear words in jesus name
i pray amen
it is the prerogative of god alone to
prescribe the duty of men and angels
the will of god is a perfect will
and must be obeyed as it is set forth in
his holy law
because every requirement is just and is
set forth by infinite wisdom
the law of god should be obeyed even
though there were no authority to
enforce it and no rewards for its
obedience the highest interests of men
and angels i can serve in obeying the
law of god
god's will expressed in his law is the
supreme will
and no invention no device of men can
take its place
obedience the commandments of men
instead of the commandments of god will
be as abomination in the sight of god
for what god requires is essential to
the highest good of his subject and is
therefore essential for the glory of god
let me focus on the end of that
quotation when you and i obey the law of
god
the person who ultimately benefits is
god and he benefits in a sense that he
is glorified because he can point to
satan and say look
i have a child who perfectly obeyed my
obeys my law even though satan had
accused god of having a law that no one
could keep
when you and i obey god's law we glorify
god we vindicate god in our life god is
glorified and vindicated that's why you
know god said to satan about job has now
considered my servant job there's none
like him in the earth a perfect and an
upright man one that feareth god and as
jewish evil god told lucifer satan look
at job he obeys me god wants to say to
the devil look at this person and hide
their bed or wherever you're listening
from that person obeys me my law is
fulfilled and that person look at that
person look at that man look at that
woman look at that young boy look at
that little girl
baby the cause of war the law of god
satan tried to destroy it but god's law
is as sacred as god himself and the
righteousness of god cannot be destroyed
the law of god will never be destroyed
psalm 11 verse 7 the works of his hands
of verity and judgment all his
commandments are sure they stand fast
forever and ever
and those who obey god through the power
of christ
will one day live forever and ever in a
world where from every new moon to
another and from every sabbath to
another shall all flesh come to worship
before me
said the lord in other words we shall
live in the new world where the law of
god will be the standard for every
created intelligent being humans those
in unfallen worlds and angelic beings
the cause of war the law of god when you
and i violate god's law we cooperate
with satan when we through the power of
christ obey god's law we cooperate with
god choose right now to live a life of
cooperation with god by living an
obedient life through the power of jesus
christ who live as you live who
conquered sin who died voluntarily who
came from the grave by his own power and
who gives you a need that same power to
live an obedient life let us pray our
father in heaven we thank you for your
word we thank you for the law
it is a law of love
which means that truly
love is obedience from the heart
i pray father my words were understood
if not let the spirit now work on the
minds of those who heard to clarify my
weak statements their god
put a double blessing on all the little
boys little girls let them understand
that you expect them to obey you even as
the little jesus as a boy obed john the
baptist is a little boy he obeyed josiah
and eight years old he obeyed you father
teach my little brothers and sisters
that they can obey you for those
listening who are not adventists bless
them in a very special way bless every
country father heal the sick they god
heal the sick and guide the minds of the
leaders of the countries that their
decisions may allow the gospel to go
forward but father the host country of
india pour out especially a blessing
upon them and the host church pour out
an extra special blessing upon them i
pray bring us back tomorrow i ask in
jesus name amen
you